quaint oh yeah Quay timbales the kid
member oh oh the little blue that Brad
will himself and the Wolverine also
helped out yeah what about they were
saying he's so he really is nine
apparently he's nine a lot of people
have conspiracy theories saying that
he's actually eighteen oh god I read a
DM somewhere saying that he is actually
the bully in his school and that he's
the [ __ ] kid hmm give him I don't
know give him a break dude right yeah of
course he's not waking up [ __ ] happy
all the time you know he's a beautiful
kid look like my sister actually look
one of my sisters he's a cute little boy
man and he's nine years old they said
yeah there's a lot of conspiracy
theories he definitely dress real
swagged out yeah he doesn't dress like a
nine year old does he mmm-hmm I think he
was an influencer or he was nine years
old but he was also like already
somewhat of an influencer like I don't
know if he was getting bullied he seems
like he's living pretty well I mean well
well justjust just because he to
influence any [ __ ] selling fashion
OVA on the side yeah kids are gonna be
mean to someone who looks like that man
so unfortunate but that's just what it
is also if I had that condition I'd be
an [ __ ] to do everybody wake up
pissed and I'd have a stick I see
everybody the knees you can feel my pain
just for a second oh yeah you talk don't
have that so I'm pretty happy I could
see you being a little guy man I feel
like you were a little guy in some
houses hey but you still have the but
the face the hands you smell weird
[Laughter]
you have tater tots in your pocket I
wish my kid yeah I wish I could get it
get to interview him and to see what he
you know what he's like but he's also 9
years old
there's nothing she's not your real
teeth ever first of all most 9 year olds
are complete [ __ ] they don't fear
been around and I mean they're good you
know they'll come in and eat yeah unless
you got a [ __ ] intend or some they're
out - oh for one thing the only candy
and game yeah they're basically just
thoughts
bro it's like a lot of these thoughts
his Instagram post same way man let's--
got candy and dick they minted a out
yeah this boy he looks like uh yeah they
had people there was a lot of conspiracy
theories he was 18 people like um put
him into like different scenarios people
even made videos of him being like older
and stuff it was pretty crazy and so
it's a real conspiracy theory that he's
not 9 he's actually 29 it's a real
conspiracy theory but there's no
evidence behind it yeah I'm sure they
could solve all that just doing a video
inside his class like they should do a
video him with all his friends all his
friends all at once go [ __ ] you yes in
fourth grade I talked to someone who it
was like first hand knows Quaid and
can't say who but he said he's a hundred
percent nine years old they don't know
about the rest of it what kind of life
he's living but he's a hundred percent
nine years old poor dude just to run put
out opposed to late cuz he's all
anti-bullying and stuff he confirmed it
- he's nine
duh no I don't give just any ideas so
ship him to Africa no Willy yeah he
loves Africa he's always in Africa
Africa having big him wells and [ __ ] mmm
you think you want that life man but
just to have you worked in brah dude
yeah shout out to Justin run and the
funds and stuff he does yeah he's the
best he's a great great dude I'll gotta
check him out man yeah um yeah I can't
imagine having like a being like such a
little guy I don't I mean it would be
probably really interesting though but
yeah when you're that age man that would
be the toughest haze cuz kids are just
picking on you so much they bully even
normal-looking kids hello miss yeah man
we had a kid that was like good at like
doing uh electronics or some or no he
did karate and we
and we ripped into him and he knew he
could kick your face off yeah I know he
has that [ __ ] ox kick with that fat
ass the backwards kick he would do kicks
all the time dude he would like he'd get
in raised and then he would threaten to
kick everyone and he would do a couple
of kicks all right you will just got
like freaked out by the energy of it you
know my school was different man we had
a kid with a touch of the downs and you
miss a band no so you touch with the
downs yeah that system of downs oh you
know there's also touch the downs and
you know Chappelle used to listen to it
dude or knowing Derek is a lot of people
are come back here transplants here's
way better we can Barry Larkin more like
a matte finish everybody probably got
picked on for something would you go
would you guys get picked on if you're
if there was anything I don't feel like
I ever got picked on in school I got
picked on at home mostly and then I
would pick on people at school you take
it out the frustration out oh absolutely
everyone my family were [ __ ] really
yeah that's how you showed that you love
them though kids just don't really get
it Yeah right
oh and you're in just in your families
how it is yeah what about were you
bullied at all Chappelle uh yeah I mean
for being the black dude that listens to
Punk and skates and [ __ ] like that yeah
that's fair yeah
[Laughter]
cheerleading out of all the things you
think that's what you get roasted it's
cuz they don't understand it and they
see doing all these [ __ ] back well
listen to [ __ ] lose they're like yeah
one green day song it ruined it all oh
yeah man like I said there's a kid with
touchdowns in my school and I always
picked them first when we pick teams
weights because you stronger than
everybody you just had that fire in him
you just hand me off the ball but good
luck tackling Ronnie does yeah nobody
could tackle him we call him big red
actually yeah yeah I also had red hair
and literally the fattest ass you've
ever seen he was like Maurice jones-drew
we couldn't tackle him dude and I picked
them first every time yeah big red they
should have I'm trying to think if we uh
if we had I mean we definitely had some
Wildcats growing up dude we had a
goddamn older guy bucket yeah we had a
guy who was at our school for so long
that they just made him a janitor at
woman but he's still carrying a book
this do mr. Larry yeah and I was in
class huh yep he carried a bunch of [ __ ]
but everybody called him mr. Larry at a
certain point and he his big thing was
when you were at the urinal cuz you he
you know he was in fifth grade he was
probably 17 so he come in behind you
piss over you into the urine and then
watch you pee oh no you'd watch you pee
we just kind of be behind you me be like
Oh what is that you know yeah there's
Larry yeah mr. Larry mr. Larry you
[ __ ] of my face but um dude this kid
named buck yet all the time it's all he
ever said was bucket bucket yeah but was
he like a dope basketball player no no
no he had full body hair early oh and
it's always tough like like bucket not
he just say bucket bucket just not stop
talk to himself bucket yeah was he also
a janitor no which would have been I
know what isn't perfect dude why I had a
buddy who was in fifth grade his name
was Brandon mine
was Brendan right they cause double B's
[Laughter]
me and double B's where we were oh we
always hung out non-stop right I chew my
dunkaroos my capri-sun
my orange slices Lunchables you might
let me apply it so much being him we're
friends I love oatmeal pies but I would
share half of it with him and then he I
remarried make fun of him because he'd
always pee and he pulls pants you know
that when you were little you pull your
pants all the way down oh yeah he still
did in fifth grade so I used to grab my
pee and shake him right Jacob
oh yeah he would just go everywhere I
thought it was so funny but then
apparently it was a real problem and
over the intercom system they're like
hey who's ever peeing on the walls we're
gonna catch it and we're gonna catch you
and you can be dealt with accordingly
dude I think BB huh he uh I think you
guys designed this where I get my
inspiration from I think Dobby yeah
that's on your side my side being BB
pieced this thing up doop and I got
caught
cuz he's doing it again and I and I was
account whatever some big deal and I
shook him and a teacher came in to grab
me by the hand the whole school oh
there's the PPK
no praise bad press all the kids love me
man nobody was there and there's four
kids though spark these memories we had
our school they had a heater a furnace
in the bathroom and some kids are going
there and urinated on it all and that
was like the big thing they do if you
had a bunch of piss and you to go in
there and just unleash it on that hot
furnace and it would just steam up the
whole bass asada but you couldn't see
yes you'd have a bunch of kids just
wandering around just in like in piss
Mehsana
oh dude yeah and so they then they had
of all the boys come into the gym
and we had a female principal miss
McManus and she and some kid just
admitted to it he wasn't even doing it
some kid is just a total wimp yeah if
you were like damn you did it actually
gave a little bit of cloud I think hell
yeah that's why he did it yeah but it
was still fun people did that forever
man just running through the piss with
my woes bro with my woes but yeah yeah I
think the kid looks like a damn child
I'll leave that kid alone man
[Music]